hello everyone there are countless
amazing stories about Bobby Fischer but
as it seems there are even more
mysteries about him it was somewhat of a
legend that Bobby Fischer often logged
into ICC the internet Chess Club and
played numerous blitz games and also
some Bulleit games and well that he
demolished anyone he came across and
there were even stories that Fischer had
some very secret matches against very
strong chess players and well like I
said this was all considered to be a
legend and until one day a Nigel short
went public with it he said that over
the past year he played over 50 games
against Bobby Fischer and that he had
some evidence to support his claim and
the wall evidence number one and
obviously the strongest evidence is that
the first match they played it was a
match of eight games and Nigel short
lost with zero to eight result and this
was well this was amazing because
Michael short was actually one of the
strongest blitz players in the world and
he said that he doesn't really know if
the person who played against him was
Bobby Fischer but that he was definitely
a better blessed player than Garry
Kasparov the current world chess
champion and in addition to this he also
provides one irrefutable irrefutable
evidence and as they play the games
after one game he has this person who
may or may not be Bobby Fischer one
question he asked him about one name do
you know a Mexican player Armando
Acevedo and in an instant this person
replied 1970 and in fact Bobby Fischer
did play one game against mr. Armando in
1970 and well as Nigel says this was
instant it was an instant reply and even
if he was to check the database and come
up with an answer it would still take
him about 20 seconds so when I draw
short said that he was like 99% sure
that he was actually playing against the
Bobby Fischer himself and I will show
you one game of this famous match that
well Bobby Fischer won 8 to 0
this is Game six of their match and
you'll see that well this is also one of
the evidences that Nigel provides as
you'll see in the first couple moves in
the opening we had f4 by Bobby Fischer
d5 by Nigel short and now Fischer plays
kink to f2 and Nigel explains this and
ok this is a blitz game but Nigel says
that well after 1975 after I mean after
Fisher went rogue Fischer only played
about 30 public games and most of them
were in in his 1992 World Championship
match against Boris Spassky and well
let's just see the rest
we have Knight to c6 by short and now
Fischer plays something very rarely seen
wait he plays King to f3 and this is
avoiding completely the entire modern
chess history we have e5 and the
official place c3 and this is
practically inviting black to push the
pawn on e4 and check out the white king
but this isn't this isn't a very good
move so we have Knight to f6 by short we
have d3 Bishop to e7
we have g3 castles and now King to g2
and now like I said this doesn't have to
be Fischer playing with the white pieces
but if you look at this position black
is much better here and well Fischer
used the unorthodox openings in old 8 in
all eight games and whoever this person
was actually managed to defeat Nigel
short with a result of 8 to 0 so well
let's see the rest we have E 4 we have
d4 h5 and the short has the right idea
here since white moves with a king he
already played the three moves with the
King are somewhat questionable it's time
to attack on the Kings side we have III
g6 we have h3 King to g7 C for rook the
g8 and now c5 Fischer completely blocks
the Queen side and now short gets
another idea since the Queen side
probably won't open up he will well he
will continue with his attack on the
Kings side so rook to h8 we have
2c3 Bishop to e6 a 327 Bishop to b5
we have rook a to g 8 B 4 and now King
to f8 and now this both of these rooks
are now ready to put the pawns we have a
bishop today for g5 f captures and g5
and rook captures than g5 + b5 attacking
the knight we have night to d8 and now
Fischer is preparing this b6 thrust but
first he plays Knight G 2 e 2 to defend
this g3 pawn so we have rook H to g8 now
doubling up and adding more pressure to
this G 3 square we have b6 now opening
up the attack on black screen so c6 is
played and our B captures an a7 and this
is a very dangerous passed pawn Fischer
has created we have Queen to c8 blocking
Bishop to b3 Queen to a8 preparing to
capture the pawn rook to be won and our
pin captures on a 7 and rook the f1 we
have Queen back to a8 Queen to e1 Queen
to c8 now attacking this h3 pawn and
well it's not it's not an easy task to
defend this h3 pawn so Fischer plays a
brilliant move
I mean whoever is playing with the white
pieces plays a brilliant move he plays
Knight to f4 and he defends h3 but is
inviting black to capture on g3 and is
preparing to part with his queen so
night natural complies he plays rook
captures and g3 with check and Fischer
sacrifices the Queen Queen captures on
g3 and we have rook captures ng through
with check King captures and g3 and now
Bishop to f5 so Bishop to d1 we have a
knight to e6
Knight captures on h5 Knight captures on
h5 and our Bishop captures on h5 and the
Knight to g7 attacking that Bishop and
Bishop back to g4
we have a Bishop captures on g4 h
captures and g4 and our queen to c7 and
King to g2
and as you can see this position is well
black might be better here but it's a
bit easier to play this with white but
that's that's just the thing if even if
black is better here which we
she kind of is if he is playing against
the facial features playing the
strongest moves so we have night 2e6
Bishop to d2 Knight g5 Bishop to e 1 we
have Knight to f3 and now rook to h1 and
now Fischer is ready to infiltrate the
last rank would wrote to h8 so we have
Queen to d7 attacking the g4 pawn now
King to g3 defending and Bishop to d8 we
have nice - e - we have bishops checks
on c7 Knight to f4 and Quint a 7 we have
Bishop to c3 and now this Bishop to see
to remove is well guarding against ideas
like Knight captures than before and
pushing on me 3 but also it completely
wall paralyzes this knight on f3 and
well what could play something like
Knight to g5 but this would allow rope
to h8 with check and then rugby th 1 and
this would be extremely good for white
although this is probably a wrong
position but white makes better moves so
black plays Bishop captures an f4 would
check we have it captures on f4 and now
King to g7 short doesn't allow Fischer
to play rook on h8 check so we have a
for Fischer now completely transfers the
the play on the Queen side we have
Quinta c7 now rock to b6
we have f6 rock gage to be 1 and black
couldn't defend this pawn was simply
undefendable so King to g6 we have rock
capture some b7 now attacking the Queen
and here well white is definitely
winning here and short plays Queen to
this Queen to d8 and here Fischer
actually has a forced checkmate in five
moves so feel free to check out the
position feel free to find checkmate on
your own it's a it's a very nice
checkmate you know pause the video and
such so those of you who were able to
find the checkmate I congratulate you
and those of you who are just here to
enjoy this is the sequence where F I
would check King to g5 we have rope to
g7 we'll check King has to go to h6
now rock the geez
good check the king is forced to h7 and
now we have rope the h1 and this is
checkmate so this is only one of the
games this is game six of their secret
match on the Internet chess club and I
chose it because I checked all the games
I thought this one was the most
appropriate and yeah I'm interested in
your opinion and this do you think this
is sufficient evidence I mean you have
one Nigel short who is was probably one
of the strongest player in the world
considering weights and also the
classical chess because well he did
challenge Garry Kasparov for the title
and next you have the weird choice of
openings by white I mean II for I mean F
for King to F to King to f3 and the
Nigel says that this is to avoid modern
opening theory entirely and the next we
have that that think that well Nigel
asked if he knew the the Mexican chess
player mr. Armando and the person on the
other side instantly replied 1970 so
yeah I'm interested this a stickier
opinion is this sufficient evidence for
you and well the mere fact that someone
was actually able to defeat now a short
with a result of eight zero so yeah
that's it for this video I do hope you
enjoyed it and as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here and thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon
oh and before I wouldn't want to forget
Thank You mark fun torment for a
contribution to my channel and also
thank you all of Hamilton for your
contribution as well I really appreciate
it thank you guys and yeah thanks for
watching and I will see you soon